others right I have a fun video game
video about video games sort of thing I
wasn't going to do this video I was just
speculating about things on Twitter and
as one dude I thought it was like why
don't you make a video about this I was
like that's a damn good idea so
I'm going to show you that you don't
have to rely on Twitter to get your
thoughts out there you can make a
youtube video so another room Studios
and WB games has released DLC
information for injustice to that is
that first they released three of the
DLC characters so there was this other
screenshot that showed these shadow
figures and you're like is that real
might not be real but I logged on to
injustice and I was like oh my god my
character select screen shows a bunch of
silhouettes and shadow is real so now
I'm going to speculate about some of the
characters that may or may not be coming
to injustice do funny thing is after I
took a screenshot of that picture that's
actually from my game I booted it back
up and now it's back to normal it's a
normal character select screen with none
of the DLC silhouette teasers almost
like it was like oh you took a
screenshot on oh case you're not
going to talk about this online this is
the internet this is YouTube one nation
under speculation first of all for three
of these there's no speculation
whatsoever Red Hood is actually the
first one coming out is legit real the
Red Hood confirms star fires confirmed
and Sub Zero for Mortal Kombat is going
to be injustice to it / of a video they
actually release now we're going to get
the obvious silhouettes out of the way I
can only say I'm 99.9% sure and I'm sure
in the DC Universe somewhere there's
some other person or entity with a
triangle hat because it's made by
NetherRealm Studios I'm going to say
that one's Raiden so there we go and if
anyone has that weird oval-shaped
fishbowl head it's Black Manta
so black mantas in it too he's also in
one of the stage transitions because
they've always done that Martian
Manhunter was in the background of
Watchtower that was like he's also
playable I do want to see Black Manta
vs. Black Manta in Atlantis and then you
knock them through the screen transition
and Black Manta starts beating the piss
out of them that's three black mantas
right there also the little dude on the
top right of the character select screen
gonna say that's Adam I say acting
because if I say it quickly I'm like
it's Adam Adam and injustice do why not
there's a little bit I'm going to find
out there's someone I was like no he's
actually the Incredible Shrinking man
from Justice League issue 19 for now I'm
going to say Adam because also I noticed
an injustice to a lot of the characters
lend themselves to having different gear
looking different Adam would and in the
bottom left the character select screen
if I can call that one that's female
physique I'd probably say enchantress
HM looks like enchantress at least from
the movie groupies attentive but she
doesn't have the top hat and Zatanna was
already dlc and injustice 1 and
redundant DLC is just like why are you
making them DLC twice I'm going to say
enchantress on that one but she really
could be anybody thank guy right there
whoever this is looks like he has a hood
broad shoulders maybe a cape maybe not a
kid maybe he just has broad shoulders
maybe he's Clayface could be Clayface
Azrael could be Azrael that would really
fit you good for a fighting game has a
good look he's a badass and he lends
himself to having different gear outfits
looking different and the bottom right
here we go my first thought it looks
like he has a pop collar I have been
hoping for Constantine for ever you look
at it you're like there are a lot of
characters with pop colors though
granted you could be Martian Manhunter
some people on my Twitter threw that out
that's clearly Martian Manhunter
I see where they're going with it cuz it
looks like it's a bald head if it was
Constantine he would have to have really
slicked back hair
it was completely possible on both ends
the reason I don't lean towards Martian
Manhunter is like the 10 he was already
DLC and again making a character DLC two
games in a row just seems kind of dick
when someone was like dead man and I'm
like that collar makes me fit yeah it
could be dead man I could already think
it's a neat game mechanics involving
possession and that you could do
with dead men also a couple people were
like spawn what I would love to see
spawn and injustice do spawns of badass
so many fighting options with spa chains
capes making spikes and come out of
sooo thing is he's not DC Comics so I
feel like that's another financial
logistics that the company itself would
have to weave through and not to say
it's undoable I'm just saying it's less
likely because it's not a DC property
we'll see about spawn a spawn was in
Soul Calibur leave it with Soul Calibur
to gamecube head link ps2 had high hachi
from Tekken and Xbox at spawn so what's
happened before the scene some people
speculate Rorschach on my Rorschach the
fan-favorite watchman's badass and
they're incorporating Watchmen into the
DC Universe in the comic books but just
see Rorschach's mask in a fighting game
would be kind of cool again he doesn't
have his hat that could be an alternate
head we should if he was looking at the
collar in the head it could be con for
all I know
point is no one really knows but it's
fun to speculate that's the fun of it
those are my thoughts what do you think
the silhouettes are what do you think
they mean who do you think they are a
couple of them are obvious some of them
not as obvious
and when I am totally wrong about most
of these characters you guys will then
know I don't know my but I love
speculating about and I'd love to hear
what you guys think point is injustice
too I've spent so many hours farming
gear in this game it's so much fun I'm
so excited for more characters and
whoever you think the mystery characters
are or whoever you want them to be
comment below let me know and it is
always a good like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]